hi there steve kaufman here and today
i'm going to talk about arabic i'm going
to talk about the dialects or versions
of arabic and my strategy in learning
arabic now
first of all
my interest in arabic okay i have for a
long time wanted to learn arabic because
it's one of the major
languages or language groups in the
world
but in i guess it was october of last
year i visited jordan
i visited petra and that kind of spurred
me on i was also in israel and briefly
started learning hebrew
but there aren't that many hebrew
speakers in the world there are an awful
lot of arabic speakers so i decided to
focus on arabic
now
um
i had a comment here
uh from uh some one of my followers or
subscribers or at least viewers
who had sort of the following comment to
make uh a he said or he or she
why you know if you're focusing on
modern standard arabic you're going to
mess up your arabic because there are so
many different
versions or dialects and they all have
different
pronunciation syntax grammar and you're
going to make a mess of your arabic
his point number one point number two he
said i don't know what funny flag you're
using at link for arabic but you
shouldn't use that you should some other
use some other fight okay
with regard to the flag i think he's
right i didn't know what flag was chosen
by our design people
i checked with them and they had found
this flag on the internet which was the
flag of
something called the arab federation
which
was some kind of a political movement
didn't go very far
and uh my viewer eric
as he styles himself suggested using
another flag which is the flag of the i
think it's the flag of league of arab
states at any rate we have decided that
we will change the flag so that's going
to happen
now with regard to my strategy in
learning arabic
um you know yes
let's look at arabic okay arabic
is spoken by over 400 million people in
the world that's a major major
language group
now
just as say romance languages are spoken
by let's say 700 million people in the
world
germanic languages turkic languages
slavic languages there are these large
language families
in my own case i have learned five
romance languages five slavic languages
uh you know three or four germanic
languages and i could learn more of
more like dacha i could probably go
after a danish so if you learn one form
of the language it doesn't prevent you
from learning other forms in fact it
makes it easier
so
if i look at my
possible interaction with arabic
most of it is going to be reading
because i don't have that many arabic
speaking friends and i'm not about to
spend a lot of time in
saudi arabia or in
lebanon or in you know morocco
but i can always read al jazeera or some
other source
uh to get a sense of what's happening
and what arab speakers think or i can
watch
you know television or radio and things
of that nature
so it's more of a passive involvement
point number one point number two i have
to be able to read my way of learning is
very much dependent on reading i like
reading
and so in any case i have to get a good
grip on the arabic script
so i might just as well learn modern
standard arabic now
modern standard arabic is a bit like
latin it's sort of the the
it's the language of the quran just as
latin as the language or was the
language certainly of the catholic
church
um
it's sort of a base from which these
other
uh languages have sprung or maybe it's
just a form of the language
separate from the way that people speak
but it has the advantage of being
a common denominator wherever you go
apparently and i'm speaking from
ignorance just as we chose the flag from
ignorance
wherever you go in the arabic world
whatever you're going to read is going
to be in standard arabic chances are
that radio and television is going to be
in standard arabic at least some of it
will be so it to some extent it's a
lingua franca just like latin was a
lingua franca
now
i do want to learn
some of the versions of arabic at least
to be able to understand them
so for example at link where we are
increasing our arabic
uh content and i'll talk a bit about
that
uh we are also adding content in
levantine arabic and i hope to add some
content in egyptian arabic so that
people can also hear these other forms
and if they need
to work more on those forms of the
arabic language they can do so and i may
very well do so
in the future
so
and you know if we look at at a map of
where arabic is spoken
uh you know it's it's a language that as
i understand it from reading it came
from
saudi arabia or yemen or somewhere down
there and gradually moved up with the uh
advance of islam so much like
christianity and european languages were
spread by armies and explorers and
missionaries
some of the same happened with the
spread of the arabic language and islam
spreading as far
along the north african cross right to
southern spain
and going east you know quite a ways
and so that languages that were spoken
in these areas before like berber in
north africa or coptic in egypt or
aramaic
uh or syriac
in what is now sort of the levant
lebanon syria and so forth these were
gradually replaced by arabic
and this process of arab
by
arabicization has continued up until
recent times when berber or
assyrian or aramaic have been suppressed
in favor of arabic
and but the influence of these local
languages and the influence of
other colonizers such as french
colonizers or british colonizers
uh
have influenced the different regional
versions of arabic
so yes
i'm going to focus on modern standard
arabic
through my reading and listening
but i do eventually want to learn some
of the other varieties of arabic for
example i had intended to go to lebanon
because i'm going to visit my son and
his family in london over christmas and
we're gonna go early and i was gonna fly
to lebanon beirut spent five six days
and i was gonna try to get some sense of
uh levantine arabic until i discovered
that the fact that i had been to israel
meant that i couldn't go
to lebanon by the way i picked up this
t-shirt when i was in israel and it says
shalom peace and salaam
peace all right so
hebrew up here
is also a related language related to
this semitic group of languages as is
you know aramaic and and so forth
by the way
uh
petra
was built by the nabataeans
who spoke aramaic if i'm not mistaken or
maybe they spoke nabataean and
eventually and they were christians uh
when they
created the wonderful
uh carvings that you see in petra and
they subsequently became muslim
all right
so um
this whole world of arabic speaking and
even related languages is quite large
and it's also worth noting
that arabic has influenced other
languages so that there are i noticed
like we started now
with farsi at link i've started looking
at farsi and i see words that obviously
come from arabic in farsi so arabic has
influenced
a number of languages including of
course european languages you know
algebra arithmetic and stuff i think are
words that come from
arabic
so
getting back to my strategy okay to me
languages
learning languages is about exploring so
now
uh we are adding content to link
and i have discovered a blogger
in egypt who puts out wonderful articles
on a variety of subjects and he has
agreed to record to narrate these blog
posts
and we are uploading these
as
content at link
and he talks about
interesting subjects for example
biographies
of some of the outstanding i've only
read two of them one is
al-biruni and the other one is muhammad
al-idrisi if i get it if i remember
correctly and these were outstanding
muslim scholars in the sort of golden
age of muslim culture which is the 8th
to 14th century
scientists
and it's easy enough to go to wikipedia
and see what these uh wonderful
scientists did
uh and it's interesting to note that
muhammad al idrissi was from
morocco but i think an arab
uh and he uh
was with the outstanding geographer of
the world up up until fairly recently
very accurate maps and so forth and al
biruni is actually a
a persian
from an area he and he spoke
many languages including he wrote in
arabic
but he spoke farsi he spoke
choresm or something which is a language
related to sognian sagdian and sagdian
was the lingua franca of the silk road
okay interesting connections here
everywhere but the point is that through
my study of modern standard arabic i
come into contact with interesting
people such as ahmed who puts out this
blog i'm going to leave a link to it in
the description box
and
and so i'm exploring i'm learning and if
at some point oh uh since my wife and i
yeah we cut we can't go to lebanon
because if you've been to israel it
won't let you into lebanon so we're
going to have a side trip into morocco
we're going to go to fez and tour around
for you know a week or so so before
going i'm going to have a bit of a look
at moroccan arabic but just as learning
russian helped me to learn
czech and ukrainian and polish or
knowing french that helped me to learn
spanish and ultimately even romanian i'm
quite sure that the work that i put into
learning modern standard arabic is only
going to make it easier for me to learn
or at least to understand
forms of arabic
that i need for particular situations
so
yeah i mean
learning latin might be a parallel to
learning modern standard arabic but if
you travel in
parts of the world where the romance
languages are spoken you don't see signs
in latin whereas i understand that the
script modern standard arabic is
standard in newspapers and so on and so
on so i'm going to stick with my
strategy but
i do look forward to hearing from
you puerto r if he has any comments
that might be helpful to me or to other
people who are learning arabic so thank
you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you